oh let's just kind of just admire that
right now
that was his skull and his Oh too late
it's gone yeah love his love is fleeting
after all hey guys welcome back to
potato mode the show where we take the
most beautiful games we know and turn
them into mush my name is Joey I'm
joined by Jean Luc here hello
and today we are playing a game that
some of you have suggested to us doom so
this was one of the bigger games that we
saw left in the comments and if you left
a comment saying you wanted this game we
see you
especially you wriggle dab Studios this
one's for you did we see all your
comments now if you haven't seen the
show before what we do is we take games
like doom that are really really
great-looking and we try to play them on
the highest settings and then we drop
them down to the lowest settings and
then we try to go even further than that
yeah and this is a good game do it
because this game is really pretty is
beautiful as 21 of 2016's most beautiful
games I think since we are in hell
mm-hmm where I feel like it's fitting
for us to go through the nine circles
and then in each circle drop a different
setting and see how we can gradually
make it look like mush okay so if you
haven't heard that now I have to explain
the nine circles of hell to everyone
that's why I guess I will rip out your
copies of Dante's Inferno
welcome to heck a friendly community so
Jean look if you want to go into the
video settings real quick so lights and
shadows okay I start off with those
first and just turn off yeah I'm gonna
be honest I'm not noticing too much of a
difference I'm sure there's some if we
were to compare them side-by-side but
this is still looking pretty good looks
like hell so what's next in the on the
list decal quality you know let's do
that sure yeah that's Olustee all right
a little money you're on the textures
will money you're booking from hop in
yeah that's a little from far away
though it doesn't really make that much
of a difference now doom you're moving
so fast like you barely pay attention
all the textures on the rocks are just
flying by you you just care about the
blood splatter and get any sweet glory
kill
alright let's go into the third circle
here as you are chained song this guy in
half so next our reflections particles
and shaders it's getting a little bit
hard to tell oh I don't know I think
we're gonna have to go a little bit
quicker than this depth of field yeah
get rid of that HD motion blur motion
blur right there
motion blur you're right thank you get
rid of it dude
still looks good Oh looks better than
the switch very okay we are skipping
this there's three circles of hell
because they are clearly not going to
help us at all so we're gonna just go
straight to the eighth circle which is
fraud
so under resolution scale just go all
the way down cool
so this will have our resolution here
640 by 480 is a way to go okay it's
gonna look weird that's the real hellish
way to play doom oh oh we're in hell now
Joey hello sir do you have any so I may
split your stomach open and reap the
rewards yes do it
eat it nice that have been really cool
if I could see what it was alright so
now that we are in the eighth circle of
hell you know that there is one more
circle left right now and the ninth
circle is treachery Oh
Joey what are you gonna do and there's a
lot of treacherous things that I have
planned so this is our good friend the
nvidia profile inspector and we're gonna
change the values of the lod bias and a
couple other settings to make it look
really really potatoey really nasty all
right I think everything looks good to
go so we're gonna hit apply changes and
jump back in oh my god that was your
cursor before it was my mouse cursor
Joey yeah oh you gonna make sure you
read up on your history of this place Oh
perfect it's all been redacted oh wow
let's go outside
boy get some fresh air whoa that wasn't
good at all about this guy yup I think
we might need to slow motion some of
these just because they're going by so
fast when you do the glory kill
okay so we changed it back to sixteen by
nine and I lost my HUD 1080p just
because we want to see the glorious
muddiness also in that process we have
lost the HUD yes yeah there's no HUD out
oh he's gone oh my god it's my amazing
collectible which one was it we will
never know
hello sir you think examining them right
doesn't look right yeah I love that
ability that's my gold one the gold ones
definitely better than the white ones do
you remember when you found that one
thing that one time because I sure don't
I'm wondering how many frames for a
second we're getting on this it has to
be at least like a couple hundred right
we can check actually that's that's that
is a lot of metrics no we do not know
what any of them do I love it oh look at
that we're getting a solid 200 frames
here all the bars are green all the
numbers are green this is a healthy
video game right here there's something
about this game just looking like mud
and then we got like well we got to put
up our metrics we gotta make sure sure
deuces run some benchmarks yeah make
sure everything is in tip-top shape so
that we we can run it with everything
looking like this oh it's like an early
360 game it was one textures that were
shiny
we're considered good yeah that was like
anything that was like shiny or reflect
had any sort of reflection you were like
yeah this games awesome this is HD this
is the future oh boy look at that sky so
we've changed it to arcade mode just
back in hell and wow let me tell you
inhale it really becomes apparent how is
it that hell okay I guess there's no
there's no question why hell looks worse
than real life but it's more hellish to
be honest I think we improved it okay
this guy this is what I want to see what
you wanted to see please yeah
also I can't see what my uh my score is
at all something you're doing good just
doing today all right thanks
we definitely broke the UI yeah yeah
yeah yeah yes yes yes yes yes yeah oh
let's just can we just admire that right
NIT right now that was his skull and his
whoa too late
yeah love his love is fleeting after all
this is what I came to see my life again
you sir get into the Zen state when
you're playing doom yeah that you you're
barely paying attention to what's
happening like the visuals yeah you're
just awful strafing everything at a
certain point this honestly doesn't feel
that different it's like yeah this is
doom good the game even be classified as
M anymore at this point I mean maybe
rated M for mush how about that we'll go
with that let's catch up let's just
catch up on everyone hmm look at that
slow motion actually just froze frozen
that's how it works so it's still moving
in slow-mo
but whatever we did to the game broke
the way the slo-mo works cuz it's not as
smooth it's like stopping and then going
a little starting a little starting a
little bit anyway let's just get rid of
everything by the way I really like that
statue on the Left right there
I love those dudes you know they look
like they actually look like if you were
to carve a statue out of potato
[Music]
those are our mascots right there like
can we ask Bethesda in for maybe like I
don't know some sort of a like a carving
maybe like a cactus demon can we get a
special edition doom package with those
in there looking exactly how they are I
would love that des des if you're
listening please please Pete Hines
please that suggests get them get them
Oh mush all around and he just
disappeared that's gonna be it for this
week's potato mode again if you have a
game that you'd like to see potato Phi
die pretty sure that's the official term
right now leave it in the comments below
and someday we'll get to it as we did
with doom right here my name is Joey
here's John Luke thanks guys and we'll
see you guys next Friday
this imagine posting it sound like the
message boards to the doom benchmarks
yeah guy Ronnie I like a good 50 150
frames per second you know CPU temps all
pretty pretty cool you know my GP is not
not even really like stressing at all
it's the only thing is that it just
looks like utter crap